permaculture je tiai capital important
nécessaire le mot urgence parce qu'il y
a un vrai problème aujourd'hui c pas un
mot ça de développement
durable le déséquilibre des matières
premières le déséquilibre l'utilisation
des matières
premières je dirais l'homme
c'est il y a le numérique le chetel
animau je crois qu' représente une
partie assez importante en terme de
volume c'est des choses sur lesquels on
a peut-être le moins de marge de
manœuvre aussi les dérives de de l'AR
industrielle voilà ne pas prendre en
compte les limitation des
ressources oui j'ai pas de voiture je
circule en vélo ou en transport en
commun et je mange ce que je plante dans
des petit petite pratique quotidienne on
essait un peu d'être colo dans la
nourriture et cetera en réduisant le
bœuf ce genre de chos mais c'est
vraiment une toute petite échelle pour
être honnête j'essaie j'essaie de me
déplacer en transport en commun à pied à
vélo un maximum de pas trop utiliser la
voiture j'habite à l'étranger donc
malheureusement je suis obligé de
prendre l'avion c'est favoriser les
transports en commun puis après c'est
essayer de consommer
local
ah anxieux oui non parce que je ne me
sens pas concerné puisque j'agis dans le
sens de l'écologie et je ne suis pas
seulle ah oui V non vim non mais un peu
un puissant
aussi mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je
suis ravi d'animer cette table ronde sur
un sujet qui nous concerne tous et qui
doit tous nous préoccuper l'écologie et
donc j'ai promis à Jimmy qui l'a bien
introdit tout à l'heure de parler
sobriété mais nous allons parler avant
tout de biodiversité et donc pour cela
j'ai l'honneur d'avoir donc quatre
invités Rodolphe Delor vous êtes
directeur général du zoau de
beauovval Kalina Rasquin vous êtes
directrice générale de sibios ingénieur
en physique chimie vous êtes aussi
docteur en biologie et spécialisé en
biomimétisme max Orville député européen
représentant de Mayotte évidemment
Sarah ah pardon
représentant
pardonnez-moi mais vous allez parler de
Mayotte et Sarah et Lairie donc
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
biodiversité nous allons aussi avoir
deux témoignages celui de Catherine
Chabot qui est navigatrice et députée
européenne et Salomé fontaine Garcia
viticultrice dans l'Aube qui nous
rejoindra tout à
l'heure en introduction je voudrais
poser le cadre en quelques
chiffres le processus de réchauffement
climatique s'est accéléré depuis un
siècle la terre s'est réchauffée de 1,1°
en moyenne évidemment ça a un impact
direct sur nos écosystèmes sur les
espèces animal et végétal c'est 75 % de
la surface terrestre qui est altérée de
manière significative c'est 1 million
d'espèces qui sont menacées d'extinction
soit 25 % des
espèces donc loin de moi l'idée ce soir
de de débuter ces universités de rentrée
avec un message pessimiste mais pour
agir de manière adaptée il faut être
réaliste maintenant ce soir je vais
passer la parole à nos intervenants et
on va parler des solutions et on va
parler d'espoir donc monsieur Delor je
vous passe la
parole merci de m'avoir invité j'ai
l'honneur de commencer merci madame la
députée madame la ministre
euh ça pe peut-être surprendre d'inviter
un directeur de parc zéologique en effet
je suis suis directeur président du
ZooParc de beauovaille ZooParc de
bovaille connu pour ses pandas nous
recevons 2 millions de visiteurs par an
je suis aussi président de l'Association
nationale des parcs zologiques français
plus de 100 parcs zéologiques dans une
soixantaine de départements de France et
d'outrem et je suis président de mon
association de conservation Bova et
nature et j'ai repris aussi la
présidence d'une association au Congo
que nous gérons depuis plusieurs années
les parc zoéologiques pour moi c'est et
plusieurs grandes missions des parcs
zéologiques nous sommes des lieux de
découverte nous sommes souvent le
premier voyage vers la nature vers le
monde sauvage vers la biodiversité pour
des enfants pour des familles souvent
déconnectés du monde de la vie sauvage
des enfants des familles souvent vivant
dans des lieux urbains et c'est chez
nous souvent en parc zéologique qui
peuvent apprendre à découvrir ces
espèces extraordinaires et apprendre à
les protéger donc h parique qui
reçoivent en France 22 millions de
visiteurs sont comme je disais des lieux
de découverte des lieux de culture de la
biodiversité donc nous essayons de
transmettre cela à nos visiteurs et de
les sensibiliser à la conservation de la
biodiversité parce que c'est souvent à
travers émotion qu'on peut sensibiliser
aux mieux au grands problèmes de
biodiversité et de disparition euh des
espèces donc à travers la rencontre et
émotion que suscit et à rencontre avec
des pandas par exemple ou d'autres
espèces les parcs zéologiques sont aussi
des conservatoires d'espèces des
conservatoires génétiques en effet nous
sommes parfois les derniers coffrees
fort de la biodiversité toujours au
profit de la conservation c'est-à-dire
que nous travaillons à international et
nous fournissons notamment de nombreux
animaux pour des programmes de
réintroduction et parcologiqu ont pu
ainsi participer à sauver de nombreuses
espèces dans le monde les parcs
zéologiques sont aussi des lieux de
recherche
au profit de la conservation insitue
c'estàdire de nombreux programmes de
conservation dans le monde nous demande
de mettre en place des programmes de
recherche souvent pour en apprendre plus
sur la biodiversité sur les espèces
sauvages pour pouvoir mieux les protéger
sur le terrain et parc zéologi sont
aussi les troè financeurs de la
conservation institut ça tout le monde
ne sait pas c'est plus 350000 dollars
par an que finance et parcologique dans
le monde des que que et 350 millions de
dollars que et parc zoologique finance
des programmes de conservation à travers
le monde et parc zoéologique j'estime
que la conservation des espèces devrait
être la responsabilité des États et
souvent les États ne le font pas et
programmes de conservation à travers la
planète qui fonctionne mieux c'est
souvent et programmes de conservation
qui sont financés par des privés par des
organismes privés et souvent par des
parologique souvent les très grandes ONG
avec lesquels nous travaillons financent
des grandes thématiques des grandes
cause souvent les parcs zéologiques ont
la possibilité de financer et la
conservation d'espèces directement
j'étais dernièrement encore au Brésil je
serai prochainement à nouveau au Congo
je serai au Mexique la semaine prochaine
où je visite de nombreux programmes de
conservation où nous apportons de
l'expertise à ces programmes de
conservation et lorsque nous finançons
des programmes dans le monde nous les
finançons sur du long terme voilà donc
je pense que les parcs zoologiques ont
vraiment un rôle extrêmement important à
jouer et je pense qu'il est primordial
de sensibiliser les S enfants d' les
plus jeunes génération à la conservation
de la biodiversité et je pense que dès
le primaire il faudrait plus de
biodiversité à l'école il faudrait plus
de cours sur la biodiversité plus de
sensibilisation ramener plus de
biodiversité dans les écoles dans les
cours dans les cours de récréation plus
de végétaux plus de les enfants les
adolescents notamment vous citent
facilement 20 marques de vêtements euh
mais sont incapables de citer le nom de
20 espèces sauvages je vais vous citer
je vais vous donner un un exemple
c'était au mois d'août 20 vers le 20
août et un ministre des Solidarités
Aurore berger MAA pai un soir à 18h et
me dit Rodolf est-ce que tu peux m'aider
pour demain qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
t'arrive j'ai 5000 enfants du Secours
populaire de scène saint NIS qui devait
aller demain je les accompagnais sur la
plage de Cabour passer la journée sur la
plage de Cabour le préfet a interdit
cette sortie à cause d'un butin d'alerte
d'orage violant est-ce que tu peux
demain accueillir ces ces 5000 enfants
il s'agissait d'une centaine de bus et
je les accompagne bien sûr donc dès au
lendemain on a accueilli ces 100 bus on
a accueilli ces 5000 enfants et vous
imaginez ces enfants qui n'avaient
jamais rien vu j'ai beaucoup échangé
avec eux qui n'avaient jamais rien vu
que pied de retour qui avait vu
peut-être parfois quelques animaux
domestiques peut-être des pigeons mais
qui n'avaient jamais rencontrer un
animal sauvage et voir ses enfants ses
yeux émerveillés à la rencontre des
pandas de tigres desé fants de hons ou
d'autres animaux céit absolument
extraordinaire et je pense qu'ils auront
de cette visite à travers notamment nos
ateliers pédagogiques toutes les
animations que nous réalisons dans le
parc je pense qu'ils auront retenu
quelque chose et au moins ils auront
quelque chose à raconter
au à l'école à la rentrée alors que les
autres enfants étaient souvent allés en
vacances voilà donc je pense que cela
fait aussi partie des missions des
parcsologiques voilà mais mais pour
terminer je pense qu'il faut vraiment
ramener de la biodiversité d primaire
dans les écooles beaucoup plus de cours
de biodiversité beaucoup plus de
sortiese nature et d plus au plus jeune
[Applaudissements]
âge merci Monsieur Delor et je pense que
Sarah partage tout à fait ce ce point de
vue madame qu vousz vous allez nous
parler de
biomimétisme oui effectivement alors ce
vivant ce vivant il nous il nous touche
ce vivant il suscite des émotions et ce
vivant il peut nous inspirer aussi et
c'est ça le biomimétisme c'est comment
finalement l'observation des systèmes
biologiques peut nous apporter des idées
des solutions par rapport au grand au
grands défis du monde euh j'ai envie de
vous demander qu' y a déjà entendu
parler de biomimétisme dans cette salle
ouais c'est moins bien que d'habitude he
franement je suis un peu
déçu
euh est-ce que vous connaissez des
exemples de biométisme dites-les très
fort oui
madame la peinture inspirée du
lotus des lucioles alors la peinture des
lucioles celle-là je la connais pas je
la connais pas donc effectivement il y a
des gens qui s'intéressent à la façon
dont les lucioles fabriquent de la
lumière pour essayer nous aussi de
fabriquer de la lumière de façon
complètement alternative au processus
conventionnel vous parleez tout à
l'heure j'ai cru de peinture inspiré du
du lotus dans la plupart des jardins
botaniques vous pourrez trouver des
feuilles de lotus c'est c'est pas le
nénuphar le lotus ce sont ceux qui ont
les longues tiges qui sortent de l'eau
avec des grandes feuilles rondes si vous
jetez de l'eau dessus ça déperle donc
c'est un une surface extrêmement
déperlante beaucoup plus déperlante que
la plupart des vêtements que vous pouvez
voilà trouver ou des surfaces
industrielles que vous pouvez trouver et
c'est fabriqué avec des matériaux
largement abondants c'est entièrement
biodégradable et donc ça ça inspiré des
fabricants de peinture pour faire pour
faire effectivement des peintures
d'autres exemples ah le train donc c'est
bien on a tous les grands classiques
c'est super merci donc le train
effectivement
donc il y a des certains trains
notamment en zonees montagneuses comme
au Japon qui sont qui vont extrêmement
vite he donc le shinansen quand il
traverse des tunnels à grande vitesse en
fait en fait c'est comme si vous essayez
d'enfoncer un bouchon dans dans dans un
espace à très grande vitesse et bien ça
génère des frottements ça génère des
vibration ça génère du du du bruit donc
non seulement voilà c'est désagréable
pour les passagers et puis en plus vous
perdez en efficacité énergétique et donc
il se trouve que parmi les ingénieurs il
y avait un un ornitologue donc un
passionné d'oiseau et qui s'est dit
finalement d'un point de vue de la
physique c'est à peu près le même
problème que un oiseau qui devrait
passer finalement de l'air à l'eau c'est
à peu près le franchissement de la
barrière du tunnel c'est à peu près le
même phénomène physique et donc cet
ingénieur a proposé de redessiner le nez
de ce train en s'inspirant du profil du
bec du martin pêcheur donc le martin
pêcheur qui est capable de rentrer à
grande vitesse dans l'eau sans faire de
turbulence donc avec un très bonne
pénétration dans l'eau sans remou de
façon à pas pouvoir de ne pas à ne pas
voilà effrayer les poissons donc il
s'est inspiré de ça j'entendu le velcro
alors ça c'est voilà évidemment quelque
chose que tout le monde connaît que vous
avez tous plus ou moins sur vous vous ou
dans vos objets effectivement ça c'est
une inspiration issue du vivant euh
issue de l'observation vous savez de ces
de cette stratégie euh qu'on a chez pas
mal de plantes de d'être transporté par
le poil des animaux vous savez ces
petites boules qui s'accrochent à vos
chaussettes en été et ben le velcro
quand vous ça ressemble quand même
sacrément au scratch et ben c'est en
fait c'est exactement ce système-là qui
inspirit le velcro velcro c'est la
contraction de velours et crochet velcro
et donc c'est ce système-là qui a
effectivement inspiré à l'époque George
deestral donc tout ça pour dire
qu'effectivement c'est ça le
biomimétisme c'est de se dire finalement
par rapport à toute une série de
problématique qu'elle soit technique et
ou organisationnelle et ou sociétale et
bien le vivant a probablement trouvé des
solutions et alors il a trouvé des
solution pourquoi parce que un il est
évidemment dans le même environnement
que nous qu'il a subi main et main de
contrainte et surtout que ça fait bien
longtemps qu'il est sur terre et que par
erreur au cours de l'évolution il y a
des stratégies qui ont été sélectionnées
le la vie sur Terre c'est combien
d'années la vie est apparue sur terre il
y a combien d'années à peu près en or de
grandeur
j'entends 500
millions j'adore faire cet exercice
parce qu'en général les gens ont pas la
réponse et c'est quand même l'histoire
la plus fondamentale hein c'est notre
histoire de d'espèces biologique c'est
quand même notre histoire la plus
fondamentale bien avant l'histoire
contemporaine l'histoire nationale et
cetera c'est quand même notre notre
histoire la plus fondamentale 4
milliards d'années 4 milliards d'années
en ordre de grandeur en ord de grandeur
parce que c'est des chiffres qu'on a du
mal à se représenter si vous faites un
Guidel Marseille c'est 4 km hein et ben
euh l'apparition de l'humanité 200 à
300000 ans si vous marchez jusqu'au fond
de la salle c'est ça le fond de la salle
versus Guidel Marseille c'est ça que ça
veut dire hein l'humanité et évidemment
l'air industriel on reste sur la scène
donc c'est ça les ordres de grandeur
dont on parle en en terme de temporalité
donc le vivant il a eu le temps par ESS
erreur de largement tenter et de se
sophistiquer au fur à mesure sur toute
une série d'enjeux sur lesquels on va
revenir combien d'espèces nous entourent
aujourd'hui à peu près pas d'individus
he
d'espèces on a combien de cohabitants
sur terreà une question un peu pareil un
peu
triviale 100 millions à minima 100
millions hein et encore ce sont des
estimations aujourd'hui ces ation les
fait grâce à des échantillons dans les
environnements qu'on arrive à explorer
et à partir de ceux qu'on arrive à
compter dans les environnements qu'on
explore et ben on extrapole et on se dit
ben il doit y en avoir à minima 100
millions sur ces 100 millions d'espèces
qui nous entourent à priori minimum il y
en a que 2 millions qui sont étiquetés
par du naturaliste c'est-à-dire on sait
que voilà cette espèce là est différente
d'une autre qu'on a préalablement
identifié parmi ces de millions il y en
a quelques milliers qui sont étudiés par
les biologistes et à peine quelques
dizaines qui sont étudier du point de
vue de ce qu'on appelle le biomimétisme
et la bioinspiration donc ce
biomimétisme c'est réellement un
eldorado qui a devant nous pour vous
donner des idées de pourquoi c'est
pertinent aujourd'hui et maintenant
d'accélérer sur cette recherche en
biomimétisme si vous regardez un petit
peu le cahier des charges opératoires du
vivant si vous regardez dans le domaine
de l'énergie le vivant il fonctionne à
90 % en entrée 99 % en entrée sur
l'énergie solaire il est décentralisé il
utilise le carbone comme ressource
d'énergie
donc finalement par rapport au plus
grand défis de l'énergie le vivant il a
déjà su répondre à ça le vivant il
fabrique toute une série de matériaux
allez vous balader dans la nature vous
allez voir il y a toutes les couleurs
toutes les natures de résistance les
différentes propriétés à l'eau la la
résistance mécanique et cetera vous avez
plein de propriétés dans les matériaux
biologiques et pourtant ils sont donc
des propriétés tout à fait intéressantes
pour toutes nos industries et pourtant
ils sont fabriqués à température et
pression ambiante avec une palette
d'atomes donc de matière qui est
largement abondante à proximité dans en
l'air dans l'eau dans le sol donc les
carbones l'hydrogène l'oxygène l'azote
le phosphore le soufre 5 si éléments
maximum utiliser pour faire toute la
palette des matériaux biologiques que
vous avez comparez ça par rapport au
tableau des éléments et à la richesse
des des matériaux que notre industrie
utilise donc le vivant il a cette
capacité de faire des choses extrêmement
sophistiquées à partir d'une palette de
départ qui est très simple donc on
parlait tout à l'heure des enjeux de la
sobriété la sobriété est un enjeu de
survie pour n'importe quelle espèce
vivante l'être humain y compris et ce
que nous sommes en train de traverser
nous en fait la démonstration un autre
exemple dans le domaine du numérique et
de voilà de de la gestion de
l'information une signale dans une
société qui se digitalise de plus en
plus et
bien il y a des simulations qui montrent
que si on devait stocker le savoir de
l'Humanité en entière aujourd'hui stocké
dans des serveurs dans de l'ADN et bien
tout ça tiendrait dans une brique de
lait dans en 1 kg d'ADN 1 kg d'ADN en
terme de compacité suffirait à stocker
l'ensemble du savoir de l'Humanité donc
le vivant il a très très bien su gérer
l'information le vivant il est bourré de
capteurs de senseurs d'algorithmes
divers et variés qui sont largement
étudiés par les mathématiciens qui ont
d'ailleurs inspiré l'informatique
moderne mais voilà tout ça on a oublié
que finalement ce vivant qu'on a autour
de nous qu'on a sous les yeux nous
apporte clairement une trajectoire
alternative par rapport à la trajectoire
que notre humanité a a emprunté et je
finiraai juste par donner quelques
exemples de très belles initiatives
françaises qui illustre là récemment la
façon dont on peut faire du biomumétisme
parce que là tous les exemples que vous
avez cité ce sont des exemples un petit
peu classiques qui datent un peu et qui
viennent du monde entier mais on a en
France des compétences remarquables je
vais commencer par un Breton qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle Franck Zal et
qui a développé une une une stratégie
pour venir lutter euh
notamment sur la problématique des
greffes et de la conservation des
greffons Fran zal est un est quelqu'un
qui donc un océanologue et qui a
travaillé pendant des années sur des
vers marins qui vivent dans les grands
fonds et puis depuis quelques années il
s'est spécialisé sur un verre que vous
voyez que vous verrez tous sur les
prages Bretonnes vous savez ce sont ceux
qui font les petits tortillons de sable
et bien ces petits veres là ils ont la
capacité de stocker énormément d'
oxygène dans leur hémoglobine à peu près
40 fois plus d'oxygène que l'hémoglobine
humaine mais ce qu' a découvert frankck
c'est que cette hémoglobine non
seulement elle stock 40 fois plus
d'oxygène mais elle est compatible avec
l'homme elle est universelle et donc il
a développé tout un système aujourd'hui
d'extraction demain peut-être
d'imitation de cette hémoglobine pour
pouvoir développer un système de
conservation des greffons à température
et pression modérée un peu plus au nord
vous avez île énergie qui a développé
une
hydrolienne qui s'inspire finalement du
mouvement ondulatoire et non pas des
turbines rotatives pour récupérer
l'énergie des courants marins l'intérêt
de cette cette technologie c'est qu'elle
permet de travailler y compris à faible
courant donc proche des côtes dans les
fleuves qu'elle est avec un bien moindre
impact sur la biodiversité et puis je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de l'ADN on
a une entreprise française une des
pionnières au monde qui a qui est en
train de développer un système de
stockage de l'information justement sur
ADN donc on a toutes les compétences en
France on a de très belles start-up on a
eu le patrimoine biodiversité
remarquable 10 % de la biodiversité
mondiale se trouve en France et
notamment dans les pays outre mers donc
on a absolument tous les atouts pour
faire du biométisme un levier et de la
biodiversité un levier de notre
transition
écologique merci Madame Raskin merci
d'avoir rappelé l'échelle de temps ça
nous invite à beaucoup d'humilité et
merci pour ces messages très positifs
monsieur Orville alors Martinique ou
Mayotte on va parler des outr-emèes et
de la richesse de cette biodiversité
oui merci beaucoup euh avant de débuter
mon propos je voudrais juste donner une
information pour rebondir sur
l'intervention de Monsieur Delor pour
dire que au niveau du Parlement européen
j'ai déposé tout à fait récemment de un
amendement pour que les activités liées
au changement climatique et à la
biodiversité soit intégré dans les
programmes scolaires donc c'était pour
vous dire que on tient compte et on a
bien pris en compte cette nécessité
euh la question de la biodiversité c'est
tout le sens de notre pacte vert
européen c'est-à-dire assurer une
transition écologique efficace sérieuse
et juste stopper les effets néfastes du
changement climatique à la fois sur les
citoyens mais aussi sur la faune et la
flore et à ce sujet vos députés
européens sont particulièrement
mobilisés sur ce sujet je vais donc
aborder maintenant rapidement la
question de la biodiversité en Outremer
disons-le très clairement et avec fierté
cette biodiversité 80 % de la
biodiversité française se trouve dans
les outremers hein on dénombre plus de
90000 espèces indigènes et près de 20000
espèces endémiques c'est-à-dire que nous
trouvons uniquement dans nos
régions toutes ces toutes ces espèces 10
% des récifs coraliens et des lagons du
monde se trouvent en France élargi avec
les régions ultrapériphériques
françaises nous avons même à maotte d'où
je reviens l'un des plus beaux lagot du
monde avec une double barrière de
coraille et c'est un patrimoine commun
que nous devons protéger car
l'effondrement terrible de la
biodiversité touche malheureusement nos
outremers également ils sont qui sont
riches divers mais excessivement
fragiles 20 % de nos espèces sont
considérées en Outremer comme éteintes
ou menacées les récifs coraliens ont
diminué de 30 % et le blanchissement des
corau est de plus en plus
important le dugong un cousin du
Lamentin est menacé de disparition en
Nouvelle-Calédonie à cause de la pêche
en Guyane l'orpaillage dont vous avez
entendu parler l'orpaillage illégal
intoxique les poissons d'eau douces et
la pêche illégale menaceent la tortue
lutte dont la population a chuté de près
de 95 % en l'espace d'une génération
pourtant des solutions existent pour
préserver des espèces particulières ou
bien avec une vision plus globale en
2021 la première stratégie nationale
pour les aires protégées marines et
terrestr a été adopté sur les 11 parcs
nationaux quatre sont situés dans les
outrmers dont celui de Guyane qui est le
plus grand du pays et 33 % du territoire
national est désormais en zone naturelle
protégé et la plus grande partie se
trouve encore une fois dans les
outremers au niveau européen malgré des
difficultés au Parlement du fait
d'alliance contre nature ou de comme
vous le voulez de la droite et de
l'extrême droite nous avons pu faire
adopter un règlement sur la uration de
la nature ce qui renforcera notre action
en matière de biodiversité l'Union
européenne est le premier continent du
monde à se doter d'une loi de
restauration de la nature cela veut dire
que nous allons aller plus loin que la
protection des écosystèmes existants
nous allons tenter de renverser la
tendance pour réhabiliter les
écosystèmes les plus
dégradé enfin en restaurant au moins 30
% des écosystèmes syst marin et
terrestre d'ici 2030 en se donnant les
moyens de renverser le déclin des
pollinisateur l'Europe répond à cette
instinction de masse car la santé
humaine la santé animale et la santé
végétale sont interdépendantes et liées
à cell des écosystèmes dans lesquels
elles existent protéger donc la nature
c'est donc protéger les espèces qui y
vivent voilà la France Sara va sûrement
parler mais moyens pour protéger cette
diversité l'Europe suit également en
fixant de grandes directives pour les
années à venir et en assurant les
financements adéquates voilà je m'arrête
là pour l'instant j'espère que j'ai pas
fait plus de 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes merci Monsieur Orville
effectivement le contexte est douloureux
parfois mais on voit que la biodiversité
peut se régénérer et c'est un message
d'optimisme je vais faire monter madame
Garcia qui est vite si cultrice dans
l'eau pour un témoignage on a parlé de
la mer on va parler de la
terre merci bonsoir à tous euh alors moi
mon domaine c'est effectivement plus la
terre un PUL ciel euh j'observe beaucoup
les oiseaux euh alors ça c'est une
échelle très locale on a parlé globale
nationale européen alors sur une échelle
très locale euh moi je vaux apporter un
message d'espoir euh j'ai constaté
personnellement la baisse de la
population de C de de certaines espèces
d'oiseaux euh et juste avec euh des
gestes simples euh de type laisser des
souches euh ça fait revenir les hubes
faciers qui n'était pas là chez nous
depuis 30 ans
euh en arrêtant de labourer trop
profondément ou de labourer tout court
c'est le retour des vers de terre on
parle beaucoup de biodiversité mais il y
en a énormément dans les sols et qui
nous rendent beaucoup de servicees donc
si vous avez un potager il vaut mieux
pour vous euh avoir un maximum de
population de nématodes différents donc
pour cela et ben il faut de la
biodiversité dans le sol qui est
invisible donc c'est pas facile à
quantifier mais quand même
euh et et euh et vous pouvez euh nous
dans les remembrements agricoles on a
souvent eu des paysages défiguré par
beaucoup de de goudron avec des bags de
rétention artificiell pour les pluvial
euh et on trouvait ça très laid mais
assz triste donc on a mis des carpes et
des poissons rouges dedans ce qui a
attiré les poules d'eau de la végétation
s'est développé puis des arbres euh et
du coup ça fait une mare ça fait
plusieurs mares en fait on en a
plusieurs avec beaucoup de vie les
oiseaux reviennent beaucoup d'insectes
différents on a grâce à la biodiversité
des insectes des différentes espèces qui
se maîtrisent entre elles en fait vous
pouvez alors c'est pas 100 % efficace
c'est toujours moins efficace qu'un
insecticide mais vous pouvez
maîtriser et avoir moins de de moins de
dégâts sur les cultures mais les
cultures c'est aussi votre potager votre
jardinière sur votre
balcon c'est les invasions de mouche
l'été c'est tout un tas de choses euh et
puis la biodiversité c'est un acte très
simple qu'on peut tous faire c'est un
petit lombri compose dans sa cuisine
c'est c'est utile ça ça fait du déchet
triillé traité ça fait de l'engrais
voilà et en fait on commence à avoir des
résultats à partir de 3 4 ans moi j'ai
vu changer la structure de mes
sols j'ai vu changer les populations
d'oiseaux d'insectes et et et il faut
prendre conscience de la gravité de la
situation mais sans attendre la solution
qui vienent de l'extérieur on est chacun
responsable et on est chacun acteur et
donc grâce à nos actions individuelles
on peut sauver localement et du coup et
du coup nationalement et ben la
biodiversité
voilà merci pour votre témoignage chè
Sarah le président de la République a
présenté cette semaine le plan la
planification écologique tu vas nous
parler de la stratégie nationale
biodiversité merci beaucoup Anel il se
trouve qu'en préparant nos retrouvailles
et ce Guidel avec mode m'a posé une
question assez claire la la question
c'était agir pour stopper la 6e
extinction de masse et en réalité c'est
vrai on est en train de vivre une
extinction de masse c'est l'effondrement
d'un certain nombre d'espèces c'est vrai
il y a plus d'un million d'espèces qui
sont aujourd'hui en danger mais s'il y a
un parti politique s'il y a un mouvement
politique qui est capable de avec
conscience et en même temps beaucoup de
responsabilité sortir de ce qu'on voit
beaucoup trop dans notre débat politique
des postures des caricatures du Yaka
faucon et du transfert de responsabilité
apporter une réponse profonde en
permettant cette planification c'est le
nôtre c'est pas pour rien que que le
président maerou est à la tête du haut
commommissariat au plan c'est pas pour
rien qu'on était dès 2007 dans cette
proposition de planification dans le
temps et la transition aujourd'hui
environnementale et ses conséquence bien
c'est une des causes d'effondrement de
la biodiversité il y en a cinq en
réalité qui font que il y a un
effondrement d'abord le changement
climatique le réchauffement climatique
dérèglement climatique la deuxième c'est
la sur la c'est pour ça que ça va faire
plaisir également à à Jimmy c'est la
surexploitation de nos ressources quand
je dis ça c'est nos ressources dans le
sol c'est l'eau c'est c'est toutes n La
les ressources que la terre nous donne
donc faut se poser la question de cette
sobriété la troisième c'est en réalité
des espèces exotiques envahissantes
alors on a tous vu lu ou croiser un
moustique tigre un un certain nombre
d'espèces qui animent notre été alors il
y en a d'autres il y a la tortue de
Californie je sais pas je pas faire la
liste de ceux qui parfois dérèglent les
écosystèmes la Coxinelle asiatique enfin
bref on a quelques espèces qui créent
eux-même de la pression sur la
biodiversité et qui font que que elles
disparaissent de son
espace la 4e c'est l'artificialisation
des sols c'est une réalité et là madame
vous avez raison la qualité des sols
elle est essentielle alors c'est plus
facile et et je suis sûr que c'est
Rodolf dira pas le contraire c'est plus
facile de
mobiliser une communauté une société
quand on a une espèce une espèce
exceptionnelle évidemment le panda mais
pas que parce que c'est beau parce que
c'est grand parce que ça nous fait rêver
mais la qualité de nos sols la qualité
de ces espèces qui sont en réalité
nécessaires on la voit pas alors parfois
on me dit s'il y avait une mesure hyper
importante on ferait quoi alors du coup
c'est pas très sexy mais je dis ah ouais
bah l'artificial des sols et je sais que
ça fait c'est beaucoup de débat avec les
élus locaux mais la question de du Zéro
artificialisation des sols c'est une
avancée majeure et notre majorité
aujourd'hui elle l'pporte elle le porte
c'est la division par deux et c'est pour
ça que c'est essentiel mais on le voit
pas parce que on voit moins ce qui se
passe dedans mais c'est essentiel et
puis face à tout ça quand on prend un
peu de recul on se dit bon ça peut être
très anxiogène de se dire il se passe
tout ça dans notre planète mais la
réalité c'est que dans dans cette
planification il y a deux combats qui
sont jumeaux le le combat pour baisser
les effets les les gaz à effet de ser
absolument essentiel et que nous menons
Mo- 55 % c'est un enjeu essentiel mais
de l'autre côté le combat jumeau c'est
la lutte contre l'effondrement de la
biodiversité parce que dans le fond
quand on ne combat pas le changement
climatique on fait accélérer
l'effondrement mais surtout et c'est là
où c'est fort la biodiversité a en elle
les solutions face au changement
climatique et je vais vous donner des
exemples très concrets quand dans notre
quotidien et bien on fait une
renaturation de cours d'école et donc on
enlève le goudron de la cour on replante
des arbres et bien en réalité on permet
au sol d'être moins imperméable de faire
que l'eau repasse l'Aure plus passe dans
les nappes fréatiques mais on protège
aussi en réalité les plus fragiles et
donc les plus fragiles c'est qui bah
c'est nos enfants c'est les enfants de
l'école publique qui pour certains n'ont
pas le la possibilité ou les familles
n'ont pas la possibilité de les mettre
dans des établissements peut-être privés
avec pour le coup des structures ou de
climatisation ou autre 10 degré d'écart
entre un espace qui est végétalisé et un
ESP un espace qui l'est pas et c'est là
où parfois ce qu'on entend dans le débat
public est trop caricaturale
l'opposition entre accompagnement de la
transition écologique environnementale
et en réalité la question sociale ou la
question de l'inflation ça va ensemble
ça va totalement ensemble et donc si on
pousse la réflexion jusqu'au bout on a
aujourd'hui dans dans la situation
politique malheureusement un des partis
politiques je pense évidemment au vert
ou à l'extrême gauche qui ont essayé de
de faire de l'écologie une sorte de fond
de commerce comme si personne d'autre
n'avait le droit de s'en préoccuper ou
de s'en parler personne on serait jamais
suffisamment quelque chose la réalité
c'est que il radicalise il radicalise le
débat alors même que s'il y a un sujet
qui doit être ultra consens qui est
fondamentalement un bien commun c'est
celui de la biodiversité c'est celui de
cette transition elle doit être
responsable elle doit être juste mais
pour ça il faut la rendre accessible et
donc il faut un accompagnement mais un
accompagnement de tous des citoyens au
quotidien je pense à la rénovation des
logements je pense à la question
également de l'accompagnement des
voitures je donner un exemple très
simple pendant la planification on s'est
tous dit mais alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire face à cette explosion du prix du
carburant on voit tous qu'il y a des
gens qui ont besoin besoin de leur
voiture pour aller travailler c'est une
évidence et tout le monde aimerait que
on puisse changer de voiture mais tout
le monde n'a pas les moyens de le faire
c'est ça la réalité donc il faut
plusieurs types de réponsse il faut
d'abord permettre à ceux qui ont besoin
de leur voiture et qui n'ont pas les
moyens de la changer et bien un chèque
carburant parce que c'est notre devoir
social de le faire il faut permettre à
ceux qui ont peut-être les moyens de
d'acheter une nouvelle voiture mais pas
suffisamment qui serait moins
consommatrice et donc avec moins de
dépendance
bah d'y accéder c'est les aides à la
conversion ça va jusqu'à 7000 € et puis
il y en a d'autres qui ont pas le reste
à charge pour changer de voiture mais
peut-être un petit peu de moyens pour
quand même essayer de moins dépendre du
carburant c'est les voitures avec le
leasing à 100 €. il y a pas une seule
réponse il y a une multitude
d'accompagnements en fonction des
situations mais pour ça il faut aussi en
réalité une réponse économique plus
large et prendre la réindustrialisation
en marche et une réindustrialisation
beaucoup plus durable c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de faire entre d'un kerc
écalé avec par exemple l'installation
d'un certain nombre d'industries autour
de de la batterie pourquoi je vous parle
de tout ça quand je parle de
biodiversité c'est que pour beaucoup
vous savez la biodiversité soit c'est
très beau et donc on parle des forêts
des belles espèces qui nous font rêver
soit c'est le sujet qui va bloquer des
grands ouvrages bloquer des grandes
infrastructures et quand VO arriz alors
il y en a certains qui sont heureux et
d'autres qui disent oh là là c'est mal
barré mais pas du tout c'est c'est c'est
je je comprends pas moi ce ce ce regard
de d'anxiété profondément il y a des
solutions qui sont possibles et c'est
pour ça que pour y répondre on a et à
soutenir le la transformation des
modèles économiques j'étaé la semaine
dernière à New York on a un quart
d'heure d'avance la France nous avons
porté ce qu'on appelle la tnfd c'est une
nouvelle norme de de réponse
extrafinancière pour obliger un certain
nombre d'entreprises avec la CSRD qui
est aussi en réalité le fruit de
discussion européenne et qui va être
transposée en France d'ici la fin de
l'année pour que chaque épargnant chaque
entreprise puisse dire quel est son
impact sur la biodiversité comme on le
fait sur le climat mais pourquoi la
biodiversité elle a du retard parce que
ça rentre moins dans les tablex Excel
c'est plus facile de calculer la tonne
carbone que de voir quel est son impact
sur l'eau sur la quantité d'eau
consommée sur la qualité de l'eau dans
nos sols mais est-ce qu'on sait faire
quelque chose si on a plus d'eau bien
sûr que non évidemment que non et donc
dans cette stratégie national
biodiversité moi je suis très fierè
parce que elle porte en elle d'abord la
valeur de la parole donnée de la France
dans les engagements internationaux
c'est le fruit de la COP la France a
porté dans le dans les accords de
Cunningham monéal la nécessité que
chaque pays fasse une stratégie
nationale alors nous on l'a faite et je
vais être hyper rapide pour laisser le
temps aux questions mais elle a trois
enjeux trois enjeux essentielle la
première c'est stopper l'effondrement
comment on fait ça zéro artificiation
des sols la loi elle est nécessaire elle
doit être accompagnée mais on doit aussi
protéger un certain nombre de
territoires 30 % de zones protégées dans
notre pays 10 % de zones très fortement
protégées les 30 % on les a atteint
c'est très bien mais les 10 % on est on
y est pas encore on est même très très
loin la question c'est pas uniquement
sur les terres sur les terres et dans
les mers parce que pareil on parle de la
biodiversité terrestre parce qu'on la
connaît mais la biodiversité marine on
pourrait prendre le temps de de de la
regarder de la préserver moi j'aiété
très heureuse que un de mes premiers
déplacements c'était la réserve des SEP
îles et le fait de multiplier par 70 son
espace et en réalité quand on arrive à
faire autant de consensus et bien on
trouve les réponses nécessaires pour
permettre à des espèces qui avaient
disparu de revenir le macaremoine avait
disparu on l'avait beaucoup chassé pour
d'abord sa chair pour ses œufs il est
revenu le castor castor alors c'est plus
commun mais le castor pendant longtemps
nous on a fait des écharpes et des
chapeaux et puis un jour on a décidé
qu'il fallait le protéger et en le
protégeant et bien il est réapparu c'est
devenu l'architecte en réalité de nos
fleuves toujours sur SN sur la stratégie
nationale biodiversité mais en étant
plus synthétique parce que je vois anlor
qui veut tenir le le timing donc d'abord
on arrête un certain nombre mais on pose
des questions de sobriété mo-s 10 % de
consommation d'eau moin 10 % de
consommation d'eau dans les chez les
industriels et ils peuvent le faire il y
en a un certain nombre qui le font déjà
mais également au sein de notre
agriculture et donc comment on
accompagne ces agriculteurs dans cette
transformation et nous en tant que
particulier comment on fait en tant que
collectivité comment on fait ben en
installant du télé compage comme ce
qu'on a avec avec l'électricité on peut
le faire puisqu'on l'a fait avec
l'électricité aujourd'hui il suffit de
regarder sur vigio qui a un outil qui
nous permet de dire quel est la
consommation qu'on peut avoir cet été il
y a eu plus de 200 communes l'année
dernière 6 700 communes qui ont été qui
n'ont pas eu d'eau potable au robinet en
France métropolitaine je parle même pas
de la situation desr mè on perd de l'eau
dans nos can pénalisation face à tout ça
il faut arrêter quand on aura arrêté
réussi le fait de bloquer cet
effondrement il faudra restaurer la
nature et restaurer c'est quoi 1 million
d'arbres à planter 50000 km de haie
qu'on pourrait planter une éducation de
nos plus jeunes génération avec le
passage de 1000 à 18000 Aires éducatives
où les écoles les enfants vont se
ressaisir de notre patrimoine parce
qu'en réalité quand on faitondrer la
biodiversité autour de nous on
transforme nos paysages on transforme en
réalité nos chemin la la beauté des
lieux dans lesquels on vit et le pire
c'est quand parfois on a parfois des
grands-parents qui disent ah mais enfin
à l'époque il y avait ça et puis c'est
un oiseau ou c'est une marre et puis il
y a plus ou je grimpais dans l'arbre ben
enfin il y en a plus c'est ça s'appelait
des e il y en a plus et donc là l'idée
c'est comment on refait tout ça donc
restauration et pour ça enfin et bien il
fallait des il faut des moyens qui sont
importants je pense évidemment au budget
et j'espère que les parlementaires et
surtout ceux de notre famille politique
vont être ambitieux sur le budget de la
biodiversité et plus largement de la
transition ces moyens c'est quoi c'est
40 milliards d'euros sur cette loi de
finances c'est un budget qui est
historique 1 milliard rien que pour la
biodiversité 475 millions pour l'eau
plus de 400 millions pour spécialement
la stratégie nationale biodiversité avec
cette nécessité de protéger ce qu'on
voit et ce qu'on ne voit pas des grandes
espèces en s'appuyant sur tout le monde
parce que s'il y a un enjeu qu'on
réussira jamais à faire tout seul nous
en tant qu'État en tant que gouvernant
c'est de se dire on fait une trajectoire
et puis on la déploie on a besoin en
réalité des solutions d'ingénierie des
solutions de biomimétisme des solutions
basées sur la nature on a besoin en
réalité des acteurs qui préservve les
espèces on a besoin d'agriculteurs qui
témoignent et qui racontent que bien sûr
que ce n'est pas un effondrement je n'ai
jamais ressenti autant d'espérance que
depuis que j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
cette nouvelle mission parce que
profondément un chemin existe il existe
si on réunit autour de la table
l'ensemble des acteurs et notre famille
politique parce queelle est consciente
et responsable et capable de le faire
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut être au
rendez-vous en rendez-vous d'un d'un
moment historique je crois en tout cas
pour l'humanité et si on est réuni ici
c'est qu'on peut y faire quelque
[Applaudissements]
chose chère Sarah merci je te confirme
que les députés seront ambitieux pour la
biodiversité n'est-ce pas
Jimmy donc je vous propose de de refaire
un petit tour très rapide parce que le
temps nous est compté si on veut prendre
quelques questions monsieur Delor si
vous voulez intervenir sur un un sujet
soit en complément ou un autre sujet qui
vous tient à cœur il y a il y a un sujet
nous travaillons beaucoup sur le trafic
d'espèces Sarah on en a parlé ensemble
aujourd'hui ave 2è comité
interministériel je devait y être à
Bercy finalement je suis ici mais à
directrice de l'association des
parcsologies qui était au côté de modev
de UCN et beaucoup d'autres le trafic de
viande de brousse via aéroport de roissi
au TER T2 est un vra Féo alors c'est
culturel aussi pour les africains mais
c'est vraiment un Féo c'est du trafic
d'espèces c'est la santé c'est la santé
humaine c'est de la santé sanitaire on a
su mettre en place des mesures fortes
pour lutter contre covid on doit pouvoir
mettre des mesures en place très fortes
pour stopper iradiquer ce trafic ce sont
des dizaines de tonnes de viande de
brousse qui sont saisies chaque année au
terminal T2 de roissi il y en a dans
chaque vaïse on était avec ta
prédécesseurrice pardon Beranger
Couillard autre jour à roassi avec
plusieurs parlementaires il y a pas
encore il y a pas une vaïse où il y a
pas de la viande de brousse qui arrive
d'Afrique c'est du pangoin c'est du
singe boucané c'est de oiseau c'est du
reptille donc c'est vraiment un sujet et
nous sommes aussi un lieu de de transit
où certaines certains trafic partent
directement vers les pays asiatiques il
y a aussi au sujet des trafics de
servailes par exemple des petits chats
africains qui sont évés en fraude en
France et croisé avec des chats par ce
queon a on les appelle des savanas euh
c'est vraiment un trafic très important
en ce moment donc nous devons mettre les
moyens en place pour lutter contre ce
trafic très rapidement je vais vous
parler d'un de nos programme de
conservation en effet j'ai repris une
association au Congo il y a maintenant 4
ans 3500 haectares de forêt primaire au
Congo une association qui s'appelle a
Congo au départ c'était uniquement la
réintroduction de chimpanzé victime de
trafique champanéis Orpin au Congo
maintenant c'est un programme beaucoup
plus large et notamment il y a 1 an on a
mis en place un nouveau programme en on
a 18 km de pH d'Océan Atlantique et
lorsque je suis arrivé là-bas ces 18 km
de phage étaient jonché de bouteilles
plastique euh et de morceaux de
plastique en tout genre cinq espèces de
tortue marine viennent pondre et venait
pondre au milieu de ce plastique on a
cherché les solutions on a trouvé des
filières de recyclage on a mis en place
des filière de recyclage de plastique
euh à pointe noire nous avons identifié
un chef de village nous avons identifier
plusieurs vages euh trois vages et
aujourd'hui ce chef de vage chez vageois
sont payés pour ramasser les plastiques
chaque semaine nous ramassons 800 kg de
plastique et ça fait du volume 40 tonnes
en 1 an aujourd'hui c'est 18 k de page
ont été nettoyés en un an et les tortues
maintenant peuvent venir pondre que sur
du sable et plus sur du plastique
maintenant nous entretenons ces pages au
quotidien et surtout ce qui est positif
c'est que nous faisons vivre trois vages
et en échange vous êtes payé pour
ramasser les plastiques en échange vous
avez pu tuer les singes vous avez pu
braconner les singes pour nourrir votre
famille il faut dans ces villages dans
ces communauté leur raorter des
solutions et et pas arriver en leur
disant tout simplement arrête de tuer j'
été de tu gorie pour eu manger ils ont
besoin comme tous de vivre donc
rapporter des solutions alternatives et
en plus aujourd'hui avant ça les gênait
pas de vivre sur des pages chonchées de
plastique aujourd'hui ces pages sont
propres il c'est ces Africains ces
cononolis sont fiers de leur péage ce
sont leur Pag qui sont propres et ils
sont fiers de de ça donc voilà des des
des projets qu'on met en place on a
aussi àas au Congo redécouvert et
amentin depuis qu'on y est grâce à ADN
environnemental on prend une goutte
d'eau et on sait qu'il y avait amentin
on a posé des caméras on a posé des
enregistreurs acoustiques on sait
maintenant que c'estes amentins sont
présents maintenant on a des chercheurs
queon a envoyé à bas qui travaillent sur
à étude de camentin pour travailler avec
é vageois avec les pêcheurs pour mettre
en place des des solutions pour que les
pêcheurs puissent continuer à pêcher
tout en protégeant et àentin voilà
éviter qu'il se prennent dans les fill
et cetera enfin je pourrais vous en
parler des heures mais des projets comme
ça on en a un peu partout sur la planè
on en a au pour les tatou géant tatou
géant ils font un terrier t les 3 jours
si tatou géant disparaît il est nocturne
personne ne voit jamais mais sil
disparaît donc tout le monde s'en fiche
il disparaît dans ind différent statut
plutôt Taal mais s'il disparaît c'est 50
espèces qui vont disparaître derrière
parce que lorsqu'ils font un terrier
ensuite ils abandonnent ce terrier et ce
terrier est colonisé par une
cinquantaine d'espèces donc on est
appelle architecte du pantanaille une
région pantanaille qui est
extraordinaire et bien maintenant nous
avons des biologistes qui travaillent
avec et fermiers dans pantanaille pour
trouver des solutions pour pouvoir
continuer à é bétail tout en protégeant
les tatou géant qui sont les architectes
du pantanail voilà des projets qu'on met
en place un petit peu partout sur la
planète et je pense que voilà la nature
a plein de ressources et si on un
protège peut se régénérer extrêmement
[Applaudissements]
rapidement merci Monsieur Delor on voit
que les actions sont amenées ici mais
aussi a ailleurs et vous avez été je
tiens à reconnaître en fait votre
engagement vous avez été promu Chevalier
de la Légion d'honneur en janvier 2023
en reconnaissance pour votre engagement
sur la cause animale donc bravo pour cet
[Applaudissements]
engagement madame Rask
oui ce que ce que ce que ce que vient de
de de dire rodolp m'évoque le
l'importance dans un monde dont la
complexité grande dit avec des défis qui
sont de plus en plus nombreux de pouvoir
faciliter euh la collaboration et
l'interaction entre des métiers et des
spécialités qui n'ont absolument pas
l'habitude à priori de de se parler et
là en particulier je vais revenir sur
cette question de de l'éducation alors
peutêre pas pas tant des des des des
plus jeunes alors ça je je ne peux
qu'être en phase avec le fait que nos
enfants ne sont plus du tout
suffisamment en lien avec la nature et
que il se crée une déconnexion totale
par rapport au vivant donc comment
voulez-vous qu' qu'après ces enfants se
sentent se sentent concernés plus tard
par ces aspects là non là j'aimerais
revenir vers quelque chose que que que
que j'ai commencé à percevoir moi-même
dans mes études j'ai voilà j'ai j'ai 40
ans que voilà je perçois encore plus
aujourd'hui chez mes enfants c'est
finalement cette contradiction donc avec
cette complexité du monde d'une part et
puis
l'ultrapécialité vers laquelle on on on
on forme aujourd'hui nos enfants je vais
parler en particulier des sciences je
connais mieux voilà aujourd'hui les
sciences de la vie sont optionnelles
sont optionnelles à partir de du bac
comment est-ce que c'est possible et
envisageable qu'en 2023 avec les défis
qu'on a l'effondrement de la
biodiversité on mette en option les
sciences du vivant comment est-ce que
c'est possible comment vous voulez
qu'ensuite ces futurs scientifiques qui
vont faire soit de la recherche soit de
l'ingénierie voilà principalement ils
vont faire potentiellement d'autres
métiers mais qui vont façonner
l'industrie de demain comment vous
voulez-vous que ces gens-là ensuite
soient en capacité de prendre les bonnes
décisions de prendre les bonnes
orientations de concevoir convenablement
s'ils n'ont pas un socle de connaissance
minimale de base en science en science
du vivant et donc voilà donc j'avais
envie de mettre en avant cela c'est que
moi aujourd'hui je travaille avec des
acteurs du monde de l'automobile des
gens avec des acteurs du monde de
l'aéronautiqu donc des
industries qui vont avoir des défis
majeurs à résoudre vous n'avez
absolument aucun biologiste dans ces
entrepriseslà donc comment voulez-vous
que ils ils aient la capacité
opérationnelle rapide réelle
d'appréhender les problématiques de
biodiversité et ou d'avoir des approches
interdisciplinaires si ceux qui
finalement constiueent leur rang n'ont
pas cette capacité et ces réflexes à
l'interdisciplinarité voilà et moi j'ai
eu la chance d'être d'être éduqué dans
une école d'ingénieur qui avait de la
biologie très long dans le curs très
loin dans le cursus et qui a été dirigé
pendant plusieurs années par Pier pierre
Gil deogène je pense que certains nomes
d'entre vous connaissent ce nom hein il
a reçu le prix Nobel et qui était
absolument convaincu que pour pouvoir
innover il fallait pouvoir avoir des
bases de connaissance dans une multitude
de disciplines pour être en capacité de
faire les ponts qu'on ne serait pas en
capacité de faire évidemment si on est
formé en silo et je considère
personnellement qu'on on silote beaucoup
trop tôt aujourd'hui nos formations et
qu'on a besoin de garder de la formation
interdisciplinaire de niveau le plus
longtemps possible avec les défis qui
viennent monsieur Orville vous vouliez
nous parler de l'eau à Mayotte oui je
vais parler de l'eau à Mayotte mais je
vais d'abord répondre à la ministre sur
le plan européen elle vient de de
demander aux parlementaires nationaux
d'avoir une une ambition climatique et
pour la la biodiversité je voudrais dire
que le programme LIFE programme européen
pour la biodiversité et l'environnement
pour la période 2021-227 c'est 5
milliard 4 c'està-dire pour tous les
projets publics ou privés donc je crois
là encore que l'Europe soutient ta
proposition et ta demande donc ça
c'était pour la biodiversité alors on
m'a demandé de faire un petit une petite
entrave à cette thématique de la
biodiversité pour vous parler de la
crise de l'eau à Mayotte je ne sais pas
si vous savez de quoi il s'agit
aujourd'hui j'en reviens à maotte depuis
mars dernier
l'île rencontre une sécheresse
exceptionnelle et l'eau la production
d'eau ne peut alimenter que 50 % de la
population aujourd'hui les ma
département français et bien subit des
coupures d'eau qui vont entre 48h à
72h il n'y a plus d'eau c'est lié depuis
20 ans à des erreurs certes politiques
manque d'anticipation et cetera mais il
y a un peuple là qui a besoin
essentiellement d'eau l'eau nous avons à
cet égard et je voudrais le saluer
Vigier nouveau ministre euh des
outremères et membbres de notre famille
politique s'est véritablement débattu
comme un beau diable pour amener de
l'eau venu de la Réunion et de mettre en
place des nouvelles infrastructures
alors bien évidemment ça va prendre du
temps les maoraais vont rester encore
tout un le mois d'octobre en grande
souffrance puisque les coupures vont
atteindre 4 jours sur 5 euh c'est c'est
pour vous dire la difficulté la
protection civile est là on essaie de
rendre l'eau potable pour les rivières
des usines de
dessalénisation vont être mises en place
mais ne seront opérationnelles qu'à la
fin de 2024 il a ordonné et pris la
décision d'une troisième retenue cinaire
c'est-à-dire pour retenir l'eau on est
en période de sécheresse la saison des
pluies devrait débuter en novembre et
pour l'heure la situation extrêmement
critique donc je ne pouvais pas ne pas
vous tenir au courant de cette
problématique environnementale et qui
affecte une population de 600000
habitants maintenant avec une
immigration qui explose donc voilà ce
que je voulais dire en quelques mots et
je voulais attirer votre attention
là-dessus je vous
remercie on va prendre maintenant une ou
deux questions du public donc je prends
la première donc à quel rythme doit-on
planifier la sauvegarde de la
biodiversité aujourd'hui pour sauver ce
qu'il reste à sauver comment ne pas
penser qu'il est trop
tard il est absolument pas trop tard en
réalité la planification elle se fait
aujourd'hui et pour demain pourquoi on a
du nucléaire et de l'énergie décarbonée
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il y a 30 ans
on l'avait imaginé on l'avait fait et en
réalité la biodiversité chaque espèce
qui est identifiée elle peut être
restaurée je vais donner un exemple qui
crée beaucoup de débat mais parce que
dans le fond le débat on peut le porter
dans notre famille politique le loup le
loup dans les années 90 il avait disparu
dans notre pays aujourd'hui il atteint
une viabilité démographique reste à
vérifier la viabilité génétique pour
être sûr il y a des débats européens sur
son statut aujourd'hui c'est une espèce
strictement protégée le castor est
revenu le maeroman est revenu ça dépend
de nous et ça dépend du coup de notre
volonté et de les le merou ah oui oui
excusez-moi je si j' pas d'exemple marin
et le
mer je disais qu'il y a aussi des
espèces qui vont beaucoup mieux Sigon
blanche en France et beaucoup d'autres
il y a voilà il faut pas voir tout n'est
pas négatif non plus faut être positif
et on peut encore restaurer à
biodiversité et à
nature alors une question pour Madame
Rasquin comment favoriser le
développement économique en passant par
le biomimétisme et la défense du
vivant euh alors je je suis pas sûr
forcément de comprendre exactement le le
le le sens de la question
mais le biomimétisme par le biais
effectivement du développement de
nouvelles solutions qu'elle soi
technique ou qu'elle soit
organisationnelle peuvent permettre à
l'économie de se transformer donc elle
n'est pas forcément on ne parle pas ici
de de de de de de condamner l'économie
mais de plutôt une invitation à à se
transform formé par le biais de
l'inspiration de l'inspiration des des
espèces biologiques alors j'ai parlé pas
mal de techniques mais je voudrais vous
parler d'une entreprise que j'aime
beaucoup qui est l'entreprise pocheeko
je sais pas si certains d'entre vous la
connaissent pocheeko est une entreprise
du Nord de la France elle avait
été largement mise en avant dans le
cadre du film demain pour ce je pense
que vous avez sans doute une partie
d'entre vous ont vu ce film là et donc
pochech est une une entreprise qui a
entièrement en fait euh réviser la le
fonctionnement de son de son site
industriel hein c'est une entreprise euh
une PME hein avec les enjeux de la vie
économique d'une PME et néanmoins qui a
fait des investissements colossaux en
faveur de la biodiversité en faveur de
la décarbonation de son industrie
pourtant cé une industrie manufacturière
euh de gestion et recyclage intégrale de
toute l'eau de son industrie sur site
euh et aujourd'hui voilà elle est mise
en avant comme un exemple d'une d'une
entreprise régénérative euh et voilà
mise en avant comme voilà typiquement ce
qui pourrait être répliqué répliqué un
peu partout et il se trouve que tout ce
qu'ils ont fait sans forcément le nommer
faisait appel à du biomimétisme dans
tout dans tous ces aspectsl et donc ça
montre que des entreprises sont en
capacité depuis l'innovation produit
jusqu'à l'intégration de l'entreprise
sur leur sit industriel et leur
territoire à perduré économiquement euh
voilà prospérer économiquement par le
biais de ce biomimmétisme là voilà une
réponse possible à cette
question merci beaucoup avant de
clôturer cette table ronde on vous
propose de visionner donc une vidéo de
Catherine Chaban un témoignage avec une
vision européenne et maritime qui fera
le lien avec ce que Monsieur Orville
nous a évoqué sur la
mer bonsoir à toutes et à tous pardon de
ne pas être avec vous ce soir à Guidel
je serai là demain pour évoquer les
enjeux maritimes et je suis assez fière
d'inaugurer cette table ronde sur
l'écologie avec plusieurs messages que
j'ai envie de vous faire partager
d'abord celui de la navigatrice qui
constate depuis des années qui entend
qui écoute les scientifiques qui ont à
la fois plusieurs messages à nous
transmettre il y a urgence parce que on
va vers un réchauffement et on le voit
leur cartes sont impressionnantes en
même temps ils nous ont proposé une
trajectoire pour les années à venir et
en même même temps les scientifiques
nous disent qu'il y a des solutions si
j'ai pris ce mandat européen et encore
merci à François et à Mariel pour leur
confiance c'est bien pour les accélérer
à l'échelle européenne et on les
accélère on sait comment engager cette
transition écologique maintenant à
l'échelle européenne on a posé un cadre
qui nous permet véritablement
d'atteindre la neutralité climatique
d'ici 2050 un autre sujet sur lequel
aussi on avance la préservation des
écosystèmes marins et côtiers on a
encore 8 mois pour que ce qu'on appelle
ces écosystèmes du carbone bleu on
l'intègre on les intègre dans la
législation climatique mais on avance
bien on travaille en ce moment aussi sur
le packaging sur la réduction des
déchets qui vont à la mer j'ai porté une
résolution pendant mon mandat voilà
plein de raisons d'être
optimiste c'est
peut-être cet espoir que j'ai envie de
faire souffler sur votre table ronde
même si je vous le cache pas je pense
qu'il y a vraiment urgence bonne
soirée donc cette table ronde se termine
je tiens sincèrement à remercier nos
intervenants pour votre engagement pour
vos prises de parole évidemment pour les
questions du public et votre présence et
votre écoute et j'aimerais reprendre une
citation de Gilbert kê
Chesterton le monde ne mourra jamais par
manque de merveill mais par manque
d'émerveillement c'est Madame Rasquin
qui me l'a soufflé et je la trouve assez
juste donc n'oublions pas de nous
émerveiller et faisons chacun notre part
pour préserver ce monde bonne soirée à
toutes et à
tous